heute vor einem Jahr am 7 Tag des
russischen Angriffskrieges gegen die
Ukraine notierte die ukrainische Autorin
Evgenia below
draußen höre ich wieder eine Explosion
in solchen Minuten überfällt mich die
Angst und ich überlege wie ich mich
selbst und die Menschen die ich liebe
aus dieser Situation retten kann
und weiter schrieb sie
jetzt ist die Zeit tapfer zu handeln und
gegen den agresser starke wirksame
Mittel zu finden
in meiner Fantasie spielen sich jetzt
schon hundert Varianten ab wie das alles
aufhören kann wie der Krieg endet in
diesem konkreten Moment
ich habe dieses Zitat ausgewählt weil
ich es wichtig finde dass wir
ukrainische Stimmen hören wenn wir über
Russlands Krieg in der Ukraine
diskutieren
ich meine
zentrale Gedanken zum Ausdruck erstens
die Ukraine will dass dieser Krieg endet
vom ersten Kriegstag an jede Ukrainerin
jeder Ukrainer sehnt sich nach Frieden
mehr als irgendwer sonst
und zweitens der Weg hin zu diesem
Frieden erfordert tapferes handeln
Frieden schaffen das bedeutet eben auch
sich Aggression und Unrecht klar
entgegenzusetzen
so wie es mehr als 40 Millionen
Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer seit mehr als
einem Jahr tun um endlich wieder in
Frieden und Freiheit zu leben so wie wir
es tun indem wir die Ukraine
unterstützen solange wie das nötig ist
ich weiß in diesem Haus findet dieser
Kurs Breite und Zustimmung über die
Fraktionen der Regierungsparteien hinaus
dafür Säge der März bin ich ihnen und
den Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
cdu/csu-fraktion
auch die Mehrzahl der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger wünscht sich das unser Land der
Ukraine weiterhin beisteht und zwar so
wie wir es seit Beginn des Krieges tun
entschlossen
abgewogen eng abgestimmt mit unseren
Freunden und Partnern und ich sage dabei
bleibt es
und zugleich wenn ich mich heute an
diejenigen in unserem Land die sich vor
einer Eskalation des Krieges fürchten
in den vergangenen Tagen haben wir viele
Kundgebungen gesehen die einen haben
ihre Solidarität mit der Ukraine
ausgedrückt und weitere Unterstützung
gefordert andere haben gegen Waffen die
von demonstriert und sofortige
Friedensverhandlungen mit Russland
verlangt
vor dem Hintergrund so unterschiedlicher
Haltung
wie also kommt die Ukraine dem Ziel
eines gerechten Friedens näher
und ich sage bewusst die Ukraine
denn sie wurde angegriffen ihren Bürgern
und Bürgern drohen Gewalt und
Unterdrückung sie kämpfen um ihre
Freiheit und die Existenz ihres Landes
darum kann und wird es keinen
Friedensschluss über die Köpfe der
Ukrainerinnen und Ukraine
man schafft auch keinen Frieden wenn man
hier in Berlin nie wieder Krieg ruft und
zugleich fordert alle Waffenlieferungen
an die Ukraine einzustellen
denn wir wissen welches Schicksal den
Ukrainern und Ukrainern unter russischer
Besatzung blüht
dafür stehen Ortsnamen wie Botschaft und
grammathorst istium und mariopol wo
Putin Soldaten ukrainischen Zivilisten
unfassbares Leid angetan und
furchtbarste Kriegsverbrechen begangen
haben
Friedensliebe heißt nicht Unterwerfung
unter ein größeren Nachbarn würde die
Ukraine aufhören sich zu verteidigen
dann wäre das kein Frieden sondern das
Ende der Ukraine
ein diktatfrieden gegen den Willen der
Opfer verbietet sich aber nicht nur aus
moralischen Gründen sondern auch wenn
wir das Wohl unseres eigenen Landes und
die Sicherheit Europas und der Welt im
Auge haben
was für eine fatale Ermutigung des
Angreifers wäre es wenn der Bruch des
Völkerrechts und der europäischen
Friedensordnung belohnt wird
ein gerechter dauerhafter Frieden
erfordert die Wiederherstellung
internationalen Rechts die Achtung
unsere Friedensordnung
schließlich hat die Weltgemeinschaft
doch eine fundamentare Lehre aus dem
Verheerungen der beiden Weltkriege
gezogen
Angriffskriege ein für alle Mal zu
echten
Putin für diese Regel und damit die
Kater der Vereinten Nationen mit Füßen
auch die Fundamente europäischer
Sicherheit reißt Putin ein sein
Kriegsziel spricht der offen aus sich
weite Teile der Ukraine einzuverleiben
die Ukraine als Nationen zu zerstören
damit legt er die Axt an die vielleicht
wichtigste Errungenschaft der
Entspannungspolitik von Willy Brandt und
Helmut Schmidt das gemeinsame Bekenntnis
in der Schlussakte von Helsinki Grenzen
in Europa nicht gewaltsam zu verschieben
ja und nach dem Fall des Eisernen
Vorhangs haben sich die Staaten
Nordamerikas und Europas auch Russland
in der Kater von Paris zu Demokratie
Pluralismus Rechtsstaatlichkeit und zur
freien bündniswahl bekannt
im eigenen Land hat Putins Regime schon
längst mit diesen Prinzipien gebrochen
auch nach innen setzt es auf brutalste
Repressionen gegen die eigene
Bevölkerung
umso mehr muss für uns klar sein
unsere europäische Friedensordnung ist
Wert unser nie wieder bedeutet dass der
Angriffskrieg niemals zurückkehrt als
Mittel der Politik unser nie wieder
bedeutet dass sich Putins Imperialismus
nicht durchsetzen darf
nur dann werden die zivilisatorischen
Errungenschaften Bestand haben auf die
auch unsere Friede baut und die wir in
der Karte der Vereinten Nationen der
Schlussakte von sehr hellsinki und der
Kater von Paris festgeschrieben haben
bleibt die Frage ist Putin überhaupt
bereit über die Rückkehr zu diesen
Grundsätzen und einen gerechten Frieden
zu verhandeln
im Moment spricht nichts dafür
viel mehr selbst Putin auf Drohgebärden
wie zuletzt die Aussetzung des news-
vom Grundsatz ausgewogener
Gegenseitigkeit hat Helmut Schmidt mit
Blick auf den Helsinki Prozess der
1970er Jahre gesprochen
davon kann aber keine Rede sein solange
Putin die Ukraine in ihrer Existenz und
damit zugleich die Grundfesten der
europäischen Friedensordnung bedroht
mit der Waffe an der Schläfe lässt sich
nicht verhandeln außer über die eigene
Unterwerfung
umso bemerkenswerter ist dass Präsident
selenski zum G20-Gipfel im November
Vorschläge für ein dauerhaften gerechten
Frieden vorgelegt hat
für die Bundesregierung ist klar
wir werden der Ukraine helfen das ist zu
einem solchen Frieden kommt
deshalb sprechen wir mit Kirche und
anderen Partnern auch über künftige
sicherheitszusagen für die Ukraine
solche Sicherheits zu sagen setzen aber
zwingen voraus dass sich die Ukraine in
diesem Krieg erfolgreich verteidigt
auch gegenüber Partnern in Asien Afrika
und im Süden Amerikas flankieren wir das
Werben der Ukraine für einen gerechten
Frieden mit Erfolg wie die Abstimmung in
der UN-Generalversammlung vergangenen
Donnerstag gezeigt hat ich bin
Außenministerin beerbock sehr dankbar
für intensives werben im Vorfeld dieser
Sitzung
das Ergebnis ist eine klare Botschaft
der Weltgemeinschaft an Putin
ziehen sie ihre Truppen zurück dann ist
dieser Krieg augenblicklich vorbei
es ist wichtig dass Putin diese
Botschaft von Ländern weltweit hört das
habe ich in meinen Gesprächen mit dem
brasilianischen Präsidenten und zuletzt
mit dem indischen Premierminister
das ist seit Kriegsbeginn auch unsere
Botschaft gegenüber
bei meinem Besuch in Peking und
anschließend beim G20-Gipfel hat sich
auch Staatspräsident
unmissverständlich gegen jede Drohung
mit Atomwaffen oder gar deren Einsatz im
Krieg Russlands gegen die Ukraine
und es ist gut das China die klare
Botschaft gegen den Einsatz von
Nuklearwaffen jüngst in seinem zwölf
Punkteplan wiederholt hat und sich auch
eindeutig gegen den Einsatz biologischer
und chemischer Waffen
Massenvernichtungswaffen stellt
aber
man kann zu Recht von China erwarten
dass es seine Ideen mit den
Hauptbetroffenen bespricht mit den
Ukrainern und Präsident selenski
enttäuschend ist dass China beim
jüngsten Treffen der G20 Finanzminister
nicht mehr bereit war zu bekräftigen was
noch beim Gipfel im Bali Konsens war
eine klare Verurteilung des russischen
Angriffs
meine Botschaft an Peking ist klar
nutzen sie ihren Einfluss in Moskau um
auf den Rückzug russischer Truppen zu
drängen und liefern sie keine Waffen an
den agresser Ausland
setzt nach wie vor auf einen
militärischen Sieg
doch diesen Sieg wird es nicht geben
auch weil wir und unsere Partner die
Ukraine weiter unterstützen
Putin verkalkuliert sich wenn er glaubt
dass die Zeit für ihn spielt
je früher er begreift dass er seine
imperialistischen Ziele nicht erreicht
und dass die internationale Gemeinschaft
seinen Völkerrechtsbruch nicht duldet
desto größer ist die Chance auf ein Ende
dieses Krieges deshalb stehen wir so
fest an der Seite der Ukraine bei der
Verteidigung ihrer Souveränität und
ihrer territorialen Integrität
deshalb leisten wir humanitäre
wirtschaftliche und militärische Hilfe
für die Ukraine für ihre Bürgerinnen und
Bürger mehr als 14 Milliarden Euro und
den zurückliegenden zwölf Monaten ein
großer und unserem Land angemessener
Betrag
unsere Waffenlieferung stets abgestimmt
mit unseren Verbündeten helfen der
Ukraine sich zu verteidigen und
durchzuhalten
dafür steht die Artillerie und
luftverteidigungssysteme die bereits
seit Monaten hochwirksam im Einsatz sind
und wir bauen unsere Unterstützung
weiter aus allein seit Jahresbeginn mit
dem Luftabwehrsystem dem Schützenpanzer
Marder und den dem Kampfpanzer Leopard 1
und 2
alle die zu dieser gemeinsamen
kraftanstellung beigetragen können
sollten das tun und dafür bin ich an der
linderberg Boris Pistorius und sehr
gezielt sehr dankbar dass sich dass sie
zusammen mit mir gezielt bei unseren
Verbündeten dafür werben übrigens mit
Erfolg
die Leopard 2 liefern wir in enger
Zusammenarbeit mit Polen Schweden
Norwegen Spanien Kanada und Portugal
die Leopard eins mit Dänemark und den
Niederlanden die Panzerhaubitzen mit
Italien und den Niederlanden die
patrick-systeme mit den USA und den
Niederlanden und die mehrfach
Raketenwerfer mit Großbritannien und den
USA
darüber hinaus haben wir unsere Partner
einen Beschaffung für die Ukraine
gemeinsam mit uns durchzuführen etwa
Artillerie Munition Panzerabwehrwaffen
und Rathaus
weitere flacpanzer Gebhard und ein
zusätzliches Luftverteidigungssystem
ihres Team bringen wir in den kommenden
Wochen auf den Weg sie werden Ukraine
vor russischen Luftangriffen schützen
parallel arbeiten wir mit der Industrie
an verlässlichem Nachschub für Munition
und Ersatzteile
und insgesamt über 3000 Soldaten und
Soldaten aus der Ukraine hat die
Bundeswehr seit Kriegsbeginn ausgebildet
für mehr als 1000 Soldaten steht der
Ausbildungsbeginn in Deutschland
unmittelbar bevor
eng koordiniert mit den
ausbildungsinitiativen der USA und
Großbritannien ist unser Land damit der
Zentrale Ausbildungsort für ukrainische
Soldaten in Europa
ich habe mir diese Ausbildung selbst
angesehen die Bundeswehr leistet hier
geradezu meisterliches
allen unseren Soldaten und Soldaten auch
den zivilen Mitarbeitern und
Mitarbeitern der Bundeswehr die das
möglich machen sage ich herzlichen Dank
ich weiß
diese Art der Unterstützung unsere
Waffenlieferung an die Ukraine das ist
ungewohnt in unserem Land
darum verstehe ich alle Bürgerinnen und
Bürger die darüber nicht Hurra schreien
ihnen versichere ich
die von mir geführte Regierung macht
sich Entscheidungen über Waffen die von
niemals leicht
ja wir unterstützen die Ukraine auch um
die europäische Friedensordnung zu
verteidigen
und zugleich achten wir bei jeder
unserer Entscheidung darauf dass die
NATO nicht zur Kriegspartei wird
darin bin ich mir mit dem amerikanischen
Präsidenten einig
um unsere enge Abstimmung vorzuführen
weil sich heute zu Gesprächen mit Joe
Biden nach washing ein Jahr Zeitenwende
heißt auch ein Jahr transatlantische
Partnerschaft enger und vertrauensvoller
denn je
auch die Europäische Union und die NATO
sind zwölf Monate nach Kriegsbeginn so
geeinigt wie selten zuvor
erst in der vergangenen Woche haben wir
in Brüssel unser mittlerweile zehntes
Paket von Sanktionen gegen Russland
verabschiedet
gemeinsam mit unseren internationalen
Partnern haben wir hier in Berlin den
Grundstein für den Wiederaufbau der
Ukraine gelegt
wir haben Klarheit darüber geschaffen
dass die Zukunft der westbalkanstaat die
Zukunft der Ukraine moldas und
perspektivisch auch Georgiens in der
Europäischen Union liegt
schon jetzt gibt das den Reformen in den
Kandidatenländern zusätzlichen
Rückenwind zum Beispiel in solange
festgefahrenen Konflikt zwischen Serbien
und Kosovo
ich bin froh dass ich beide Seiten
Präsident bucic und Premierminister
Kurti Anfang dieser Woche klar zum
deutsch-französischen Vorschlag für eine
Grundlagenvereinbarung bekannt haben wir
werden diesen Prozess mit Nachdruck
weiterverfolgen
auch bei der engen Verzahnung der
Verteidigungsindustrie in Europa kommen
wir voran dafür stehen gemeinsame
Projekte wie FKS das künftige
luftkampfsystem mit Frankreich und
Spanien und die von Deutschland
initiierte Europe
zur Stärkung von Europas
Luftverteidigung im Rahmen der NATO
gerade erst haben sich mit Schweden und
Dänemark zwei weitere enge Freunde
diesem Vorhaben angeschlossen
und schließlich haben wir Europäer uns
im Zeitraffer aus der Abhängigkeit von
Öl Gas und Kohle aus Russland gelöst und
zugleich beim Aufbau einer
klimaneutralen europäischen Industrie
den Turbo gezündet
Repower EU gezielte industriefördern für
den cleantec-bereich vereinfachte
beihilfe-regeln mehr Investitionen in
klimafreundlichen und digitalen Wandel
eine batterieallianz den Chips Act all
das haben wir in kürzester Zeit aufs
gleisgesetz all das sind zugleich
Schritte zu einem geopolitischen Europa
zu Europa das international
wettbewerbsfähig ist und auch durch neue
Freihandelsabkommen und
rohstoff-olaren Welt des 21 jahrhunderts
behauptet und Standards
auch Deutschland ist im Licht der der
Zeitenwende widerstandsfähige geworden
am deutlichsten wird das wenn man auf
die Bundeswehr blickt wir machen Schluss
wir machen muss Schluss mit der
Vernachlässigung unserer Streitkräfte
dafür steht das Sondervermögen
Bundeswehr und ich bin dankbar für die
breite Unterstützung dafür auch seitens
der größten Oppositionsparteien
dafür steht aber auch der Aufwuchs des
Verteidigungshaushalts insgesamt damit
wir dauerhaft das 2% Ziel der NATO
erreichen
diese Zusage die hier am 27 Februar
vergangenen Jahres gegeben habe gilt
wichtige Beschaffungsverfahren haben wir
eingeleitet etwa den F35 Kampfjet ein
Großteil der für das Sondervermögen
vorgesehenen Projekte soll noch in
diesem Jahr unter Vertrag sein das sind
zumeist langfristige Vorhaben für die
Aufgaben aus dem Sondervermögen
entsprechend geleistet werden
auch die Nachbeschaffung etwa von
Panzerhaubitzen Munition und anderen
Gütern die wir aus Beständen der
Bundeswehr an die Ukraine geliefert
haben wird in den kommenden Monaten
unter Dach und Fach gebracht
wir tun all das auch mit Blick auf
unsere gewachsene Verantwortung und die
gestiegenen Erwartungen die unsere
Bündnispartner zurecht an Deutschland
als bevölkerungsreiches und
wirtschaftsstärkstes Land Europas
richten
letztes Jahr am 27 Februar habe ich hier
im Bundestag gesagt
wir stehen ohne wenn und aber zu unserer
Beistandspflicht in der NATO
und auch diesen Worten lassen wir taten
folgen
mit einer eigens designierten Brigade
zum Schutz Litauens mit der
Unterstützung Polens und der Slowakei
bei der Flugabwehr mit unserer Marine
und Bundespolizei die sich zusammen mit
Norwegen und anderen um den Schutz
kritischer Infrastruktur in Nord- und
Ostsee kümmern
indem wir in diesem Jahr die
nato-schützen führen und dafür 17.000
Soldaten und Soldaten in hoher
Bereitschaft halten und indem wir ab
2025 zunächst 30.000 Soldaten und
Soldaten für die künftige nato-
Industrie über einen echten Spurwechsel
hin zu einer schnellen planbaren und
leistungsfähigen Beschaffung von
Rüstungsgüter für die Bundeswehr und
andere europäische Armee
wir brauchen eine laufende Produktion
von wichtigen Waffen Geräten und
Munitionen das erfordert langfristige
Verträge und Anzahlung um
Fertigungskapazitäten aufzubauen
so schaffen wir hier in Deutschland eine
industrielle Basis die ein Beitrag
leistet zur Sicherung von Frieden und
Freiheit in Europa auch das ist eine
Erkenntnis der Zeitenwende
wenn wir Sicherheitsfragen im Licht der
Zeitenwende neu denken dann geht es
nicht nur um militärische Fähigkeiten
wir haben den vergangenen zwölf Monaten
Desinformationskampagnen erlebt
sabotageakter an kritischer
Infrastruktur auch Cyberangriffe
auch dagegen wappnen wir uns denn freie
offene Gesellschaft wie unsere müssen
auch im Inneren stark und
widerstandsfähig sein
wie stark und widerstandsfähig wir sein
können
das haben wir gezeigt als Russland uns
mit dem Stopp von Energielieferungen
unter Druck gesetzt hat denn wir sind
gut durch diesen Winter gekommen auch
ohne russische Gaslieferung
vom kalten Wohnungen war die Rede von
der Zwangsabschaltung ganzer
Industriezweige vom
Produktionsstillstand von einem heißen
Herbst und wutwinter
nichts davon ist eingetreten weil wir
entschlossen gehandelt haben weil wir
zusammen geblieben sind und hinter
diesem wir steht unser ganzes Land
haben wuchtige entlastungspakete
geschnürt dadurch sind die
Großhandelspreise gefallen das kommt nun
auch bei den Verbrauchern und
Verbrauchern an wir haben die
gastspeicher so gefüllt dass sie heute
noch zu mehr als 70% voll sind das ist
ein gutes Polster um sicher auch durch
den nächsten Winter zu kommen
eine enorme Hilfe dabei ist dass die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger weiter Energie
sparen viele bauen sich zu Hause neue
Wärmepumpen und Solaranlagen ein andere
haben das vor
Unternehmen haben ihre Energieversorgung
umgerüstet und investieren in
klimafreundliche Produktion und
schließlich haben wir im Rekordtempo
neue LNG Terminals und Leitungen in
Betrieb genommen
es waren die vielen hervorragend
ausgebildeten Ingenieurinnen und
Ingenieure in unserem Land unsere
tüchtigen FacharbeiterInnen und
Facharbeiter
unsere Handwerker und Handwerkerinnen
und noch ganz viele andere die das alles
möglich gemacht haben ihnen allen sagen
wir heute herzlichen Dank
von der neuen Deutschland
Geschwindigkeit habe ich gesprochen ich
wünsche mir dass wir die wir diese
Deutschland Geschwindigkeit beibehalten
als Fortschritt den unser Land aus der
Zeiten Wende mitnimmt besonders wichtig
ist das mit Blick auf die industrielle
Transformation und den Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien
2022 waren die Erneuerbaren bereits für
fast die Hälfte der Stromproduktion
verantwortlich Tendenz deutlich steigend
weil wir bürokratische Hürden für den
Ausbau beseitigt haben weil wir uns mit
den Ländern auf klare Flächen Ziele
verständigt haben weil der Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren nun als überragendes
öffentliches Interesse gesetzlich
festgeschrieben wird
mit den bereits beschlossenen Gesetzen
verdreifachen wir den Ausbau zu Wasser
zu Land und auf dem Dach immer mit dem
Ziel bis 2030 80 Prozent unseres Stroms
aus erneuerbaren Energien zu produzieren
all das war schon vor der Zeitenwende
richtig jetzt aber sind diese Aufgaben
noch wichtiger noch dringendiger und mit
dieser Dringlichkeit gehen wir Sie auch
an
Russlands Angriffskrieg der Bruch des
Völkerrechts und der europäischen
Friedensordnung diese zeigten wenn der
hat uns allen viel abverlangt in den
vergangenen zwölf Monaten
am meisten natürlich den Ukrainerinnen
und Ukrainern die um ihr Leben kämpfen
und zugleich haben wir mehr erreicht als
viele uns zugetraut haben
die Ukraine behauptet ihre Freiheit und
Unabhängigkeit gegen Russlands
Aggression auch mit unserem
Unterstützung
die Einigkeit von Europäischer Union G7
und NATO ist gewahrt gerade in dieser
Krise haben wir sie weiter gestärkt
und wir haben den Winter gut überstanden
auch ohne Gas aus Russland
und wir investieren in die Sicherheit
unseres Landes in unsere Bundeswehr in
unsere Energieinfrastruktur in die
Zukunft unserer Wirtschaft und Energie
Versorgung
am Ende ihres eingangs zitierten
Tagebucheintrags vom zweiten März 2022
schreibt die Ukrainerinnen
als die Ukraine die man verteidigen muss
es gibt Situationen in den Widerstand
die Rettung bedeutet
schönen Dank
[Applaus]
[Musik]